the gyro can experience
I was listening my friend Ryan
callaghan's podcast today it's a cow's
Week in Review and he was talking about
this animal that they this bird rather
that people eat and they drowned this
bird in brandy they take this a tiny
bird each one of them is like just a few
ounces and they drowned them in brandy
and then when you eat them you eat them
whole you need everything the guts you
eat the the tissue the skin that's
that's that's where it is what is the
name of it what how do i how do i
pronounce a bordelon bunt Bordelon and
so when you eat it you put a napkin over
your head traditionally when they eat it
and as they eat it
Bourdain was the first one to tell me
about this [ __ ] that oh no it was Duncan
Duncan Trussell was the first person to
tell me about the [ __ ] and so they boys
in love they soak the bird in Brant they
drown it okay they drown it in brandy
and then they cook it somehow or another
but anyway go back to that picture where
those guys are eating it where you could
see the go back to the picture with the
yeah see how they have those things over
their head they hook these napkins over
their head to take in the aromas and to
trap the aromas and they also do it to
hide their face from God does the idea
yeah kind of people are these I think
it's most I think it's Europeans I think
it's something that in in France it's
popular it's a popular dish and it's
it's endangered not endangered now but
there yeah it's okay ortolans could
francis cruelest food be back in the
menu as French chefs lobby for Ortolan
to be reintroduced onto menus we explain
why cooking the rare and delicate
songbird is so controversial so that's
even grosser right it's a songbird like
how they named it a songbird not it's
not a little tiny dinosaur no no it's a
songbird it just wants to sing for you
yeah make the woods bright tweet tweet
tweet
no man it's a weird little tiny animal
this is why is it illegal to cook and
kill an Ortolan the RS
Phoebe lists their status as vulnerable
and throughout the 1970s and 1980s
numbers in France to clydra matically as
poachers caught vast numbers to supply
restaurants where the bird has long been
considered a rare and expensive delicacy
some restaurants would charge over fifty
pounds for the dish
what is that in euros or pounds pound
that's pounds we think that cost what's
50 pounds it's not like a hundred bucks
something like that France is league for
the protection of birds claimed order
LAN numbers plunged 30 percent between
97 and 2007 as many as 1,500 poachers
catching an estimated 30,000 live birds
a year so they're just decimating these
[ __ ] things the method of capture and
killing them is what's [ __ ] up about
it so the hunters catch the birds using
traps in the fields they're kept in
cages encouraging them to gorge on grain
in order to double their size and it
said the Roman emperors stabbed out
their eyes in order to make the birds
think it was night making them eat even
more oh okay here it goes
and then how are they killed this is
where the squeamish look away what is
the name this website so we give people
that's a telegraph autograph from The
Telegraph what is the name of the
article well we'll tell we'll say it at
the end you say how were they killed
says this is where the squeamish need to
look away traditionally in France the
fat and little birds are drowned in a
vat of Armagnac I guess it's like a
cognac or something what is it Armagnac
yeah you're probably dead on okay
managing to snuff out their lives and
marinate them at the same time killing
two birds with one glug as it were it
says here in the article French chefs
argue that it's not a bad way to die in
quotes what the [ __ ] but I suppose it
might be less cruel than throwing a live
lobster into a pot of boiling water
anyway so that's how they drown them and
then they cook them and then you eat the
whole [ __ ] thing bones and all on the
bones puncture your mouth and [ __ ] and
that's part of it like you taste your
own blood as you're eating these [ __ ]
things yeah people are weird man you
leave them alone for long enough let
them get drunk and buy